all the TV writers in Hollywood have
reached a deal with the studios which
means there will not be a writer strike
no write aside in fact in fact my
writers plan to get back to work about
three jokes from now so that's why I was
killing all that time up front right
they're still phoning it in what else is
going on everyone talking about the new
health care plan possibility analysts
are saying that Donald Trump has not
read his new health care plan and in
fact he has actually spent no time
getting familiar with it yeah the first
hint was when he called it Melania Hunt
which one of you today there was a call
between Russian President Vladimir Putin
and President Trump they had a phone
call yeah
the call was all part of Putin's annual
employee review
House Republicans are trying to once
again repeal and replace Obamacare even
though they don't have the votes yeah
House Republicans defended themselves
and said please it's a soothing ritual
that comforts us let us do it we like to
repeal and replace we like to do this
like every three months yeah
while discussing health care I can't
believe this a Republican congressman
from Alabama said that people who lead
good lives don't get sick now seconds
later he dropped dead
German Chancellor Angela Merkel says she
is confident that fake news will not
harm her chances in Germany's election
yeah
in fact Merkel is so confident she's
gonna win she's not even going to
campaign in Wisconsin so wasn't sure
that would work we debated it backstage
I said give it a chance
I was wrong as part of a limited
campaign McDonald's is offering Forks
made from french fries french fries yeah
not to be outdone today Long John
Silver's began offering seafood made
from fish
who's eating it long john silver's
recently anybody didn't see no it's it's
an easy restaurant to go after cuz no
one care for all one person it's like
that's me restaurant you're talking
about probably no they no longer exist
they probably haven't existed for years
but I found that that's the safe chain
to go after right you mentioned another
one if you mentioned burgers oh I like
Burger King and someone's out long john
silver's no one cares and that's the
American Way
you